[Music]
foreign
the name's Harry
well thank God in heaven for the work
that you're doing Harriet
before you thank me
let me tell you
I've LED hundreds of slaves to freedom
through this here on the ground wherever
it ain't gonna be easy
are you ready
all right
then hike up your britches
and follow me to Freedom
[Music]
watch this black molasses
foreign
[Music]
that was an easy part now stay close
this next 500 Miles gets a little sticky
[Music]
forget this man I'm going back
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Gotta Get It Down
Spanish
[Music]
[Applause]
gotta put it down
[Music]
hey what the hell are we saying man I
got no idea man I'm just hungry and
talking about the Galaxy and trains I
think they're buying it though
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
championships
representing the body shop from
Hollywood California flag
[Applause]
[Music]
and from the skin Shop Detroit Michigan
lightning
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the matter rich in the next
episode Steve Urkel turns Carl into a
giant sandwich and accidentally eats him
come on I'm an actor Gene this was
supposed to be about me and my family I
know but you know after that after that
first death spot with Steve Urkel I mean
America fell in love with him man we had
to make him a regular and you know Hey
listen he's the star of the show now
sweetheart we gotta play ball bubble
don't you dare Bubble Up me Gene now
last week Steve used his transformation
machine to turn Carl into a car and
drive him around the Monaco Grand Prix
come on how many times we're going to
use this transformation machine this is
supposed to be a blue collar Cosby Show
now you turn it into goddamn Quantum
Leap all right I couldn't tell you even
if I wanted to okay man we got like 21
writers up there okay you know what I'm
saying original but you and I both know
but they don't decide what happens to
the show okay we both know who decides
what happens in the show two weeks ago
Steve Urkel used his invisibility Ray on
Carl and I wasn't even in the goddamn
episode it was just my voice yes I know
I know Rachel I'm sorry I apologize will
never happen again Dan Steve used his
voice changing ready to turn Carl into a
high-pitched nerdy Voice who do you
think provides the voice for that don't
get too feisty on me now reg let's not
go down that path okay oh oh we are
going down that path Gene in a couple of
weeks Harriet Eddie Laura grandma on
racial Little Richie and the other
little kid are gonna get teleported to
another dimension and then Steve injects
Carl with his own DNA so Carl turns into
another Steve Urkel that's two Steve
urkels and no family on the show called
Family Matters does that work listen
right to the hook Mania is Unstoppable
okay he's a phenomenon there's nothing
we can do about okay it's up to
him no no no no no no no I'm an actor
I'm a [__] actor I'm a real actor I
think Richard III I was in true West
with Sherman Helmsley I was in Die Hard
damn it
Steve Urkel you will suck Steve Urkel's
give me one two two you will suck it you
understand he has our bread and butter
you mother I am high on cocaine
and more cocaine than you weigh
[__] I'm gonna tell you what you
are rational Val Johnson you're a pawn
in that nerd's game you are a pawn do
you think I have any power ever let that
monster does any power at all
I am the Seeker vice president of
development for the American bro
Jane
what's become of Eugene
I
am nothing
do you not I don't know what you mean by
that team but you're scaring me no no
don't don't do anything crazy everyone
does too much coke sometimes but just
what are you gonna do with the gun Gene
what are you gonna do no no no no no no
no no
through
okay
long live the king
did I do that
[Music]
there is no Jaleel
only Steve
it's always been Steve
Steve
[Music]
forgetting something Carl
don't you come near me stay away from me
here could have all been so simple Carl
just say your lines
and take the money
what are you doing
I I can't control am I doing this no no
no no no no no no no see I
want
yes
oh of course Steve
[Music]
see you on set Carl
I'll Steve
[Music]
foreign
there's got to be another human being
out there somewhere
[Music]
somewhere
100 and
is doing
[Music]
today
I may be the last man alive
however
there is another I will find them
is more than I could
whoa
God
um
[Music]
[Applause]
no hey dude oh hey oh oh come over there
dude hey
I'll come to you man
[Music]
there's gotta be another
out there somewhere
[Music]